[Musique]
quand j'étais petit garçon je repasse
mes
leçons en
chantant et bien des années plus tard je
chassais mes idées noires en
chantant c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant
de parler du mauvais temps en
chantant
et c'est tellement plus mignon de se
faire traiter de con en
chanson la vie c'est plus marrant c'est
moins désespérant en
chantant la première vie de ma vie dans
la rue je l'ai
suivi en
chantant quand elle s'est déshabillé
j'ai joué le vieil habitué en chantant
j'étais si content de moi que j'ai fait
l'amour 10 fois en
chantant mais je ne peux pas m'expliquer
qu'au matin elle m'est quittait
enchantée l'amour c'est plus marrant
c'est moins
désespérant en
chantant tous les hommes vont en galère
à la pêche ou à la guerre
en
chantant la fleur au bout du fusil la
victoire se gagne aussi en
chantant on le parle à Jéhovah à Jupiter
à
Boudha qu'en
chantant quel que soi nos opinions on
fait sa
révolution en
chanson le monde est plus marrant c'est
moi un des espérant en
chantant puisqu'il faut mourir enfin que
ce soit côes jardins en
[Musique]
chantant si ma femme a de la peine que
mes enfants la
soutiennent en
chantant quand j'irai revoir mon père
qui m'attend les bras
ouverts en
chantant j'aimerais que sur la terre
tous mes bons copains
m'enta en
chantant la mort c'est plus marrant
c'est moins
désespérant en
chantant quand j'étais petit garçon je
repassais mes leçons en
chantant et bien des années plus tard je
chassais mes idées
noires en
chantant c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant
de parler du mauvais
temps en
chantant et c'est tellement plus mignon
de se faire traiter de con en
[Musique]
chanson
na
[Musique]